hi there steve kaufman here again uh the
linguist on language blog
founder of link
and uh there seems to be a lot of
interest in this subject of testing and
language learning so i thought i would
do
another video here while the subject is
still fresh in my mind
and uh i've sort of gave it some more
thought you know one thing that we do
like to do as humans
uh in all fields of endeavor is we do
like to measure our achievements we we
do like to in a sense test ourselves
so
presumably language learning is no
exception
uh i mean if we play tennis we like to
see how well we do we compete against
other tennis players
in golf we keep score so
uh yeah we would like to keep score in
our language learning
so i kind of thought it through and i
suggest that there are
three types of language testing or
language measurement
that matter the first and the most
important
is how we measure our own achievements
and this is the most important for the
simple reason
that um
language learning is all about ourselves
i mean we learn the language primarily
for ourselves it's our own activity it's
something that we do for ourselves it's
quite different from
i think was reinecke who one of the one
of a frequent and very welcome commenter
at my blog
uh was saying well you know we have to
measure things like we have driving
tests
yeah we have driving tests because we
can't have people on the road who can't
drive
driving is not a subjective something
that you just do for your own personal
enjoyment type of activity driving is
something that gets you from a to b
and also it involves the other people on
the road if you can't drive if you don't
know the rules of the road uh you are a
menace
um
you know similarly we have to have tests
for
people who are electricians or plumbers
or engineers
uh airline pilots uh you know even in
the field of language uh people who are
interpreters we need to determine just
what their skill level is
but most people learn languages for
their own purposes so
it's less important to have
even if such a thing were possible to
have some kind of an objective test for
most people
however people do want to measure
so the first thing is
my best test is you know how well do i
understand what i'm listening to
how well can i read a book
how difficult a book can i read
how much trouble do i have expressing
myself
most of us are pretty good
at self-evaluating at length we have six
levels and as long as there's no
pressure as long as i'm not trying to
get a job or prove to someone that i
have a skill which maybe i don't quite
have if there's no such
other reason people are quite capable of
evaluating themselves on a scale of of
one to six for example
low be you know absolute beginner uh
advanced beginner
lower intermediate advanced intermediate
uh sort of
somewhat advanced and very advanced
let's say six levels most people can do
that
and even if they don't measure
themselves on that scale
they're constantly aware of of
how well they're doing
however some people are not satisfied
with that and some people like to
compare themselves
so you know at link we do have
a measurement of the number of words you
know
we measure every form of the word so
depending on the language that can end
up being a large number because in some
languages
were the you know that are very
inflected as we say the words can have
many different forms depending on
case or depending on gender or depending
on
you know tense and person and so forth
and so on
so that's a measurement
there are very simple tests uh called
closed tests closed
where you look at attack
text and certain words are blank
and
then you have to pick the right word so
that's a measurement of how if you
according to links statistics claim to
know ten thousand words whether in fact
you do know them
um
a relatively easy thing to do in fact we
intend to introduce it
when we eventually have the time
at link so those are
the number of ways in which you can test
yourself but the best way really is you
have a good sense yourself of how well
you're communicating
uh if anything people tend to
underestimate their abilities so that's
insofar as testing yourself
the next issue is how do we test a
student and people have commented on my
blog we need to know whether the kids
are learning well
here i think the most important thing is
to test
the activity level of the student
and again that's something we attempt to
do at link we try to measure how many
hours of listening how many
words of reading
how many words of writing
how many hours of speaking
even the number of as we call them links
how many words and phrases have you
saved to your database you have to be
reading in order to be saving those to a
database so there are a number of things
that you can do
whether you're at a a
community like link which is on the
internet where we have ways of measuring
certain things or in a classroom
how many books have the kids read what
stories have they listened to
if you're asking them to bring in their
favorite words and phrases which i
suggest as some as an activity for the
classroom then are they bringing in
these words and phrases
uh you can also discuss with them what
they have read or claim to have read and
claim to have listened to so there are
ways of measuring the amount of activity
that kids are into without actually
testing them it's not a comprehension
test on whether you understood the book
it's merely a discussion about the book
just to get some sense that that the
student has in fact read the book or
listened to the book
or you know if have to bring in lists of
words and phrases that they liked or
want to learn these are all indications
that they are active and so i think that
the the most important thing in in
measuring the learner
rather than the learner measuring
themselves
is to measure the degree to which
they're active how much time are they
spending with the language
uh
of course we have other ways of testing
their ability i mean at some point
although not for the first few years
they will write and you will correct the
writing uh you will speak if you're a
teacher you will have an opportunity to
speak to them or they will speak to
others so you have a number of more
informal ways of measuring
their familiarity and comfort level in
the language
but you needn't give them a an 8 out of
10 and mark them down on the use of the
subjunctive for example
finally
the issue is how do we
test or measure
the school or the teacher the person
who's supposed to be
teaching these kids
one of the justifications for
testing is that it's also a test
of how effective the school is
or the teacher or the program
well my comment here is that our schools
are full of tests and yet the ultimate
test is that a very high percentage of
kids graduate not being able to use the
language
that's a pretty strong condemnation of
the school now how if you introduced a
new
approach how would you measure its
effectiveness
i think that
judging how well someone uses the
language
is not so difficult
and if the net result is that
the student
is comfortable with their own
achievements in the language in other
words that first type of testing that i
talked about which is aimed at
self-evaluating
if
you have numbers that show that the
students are very active in the language
that is that second group measuring
their level activity level of activity
and if you have applied
a form of language education that is
based on letting kids choose what to
learn and what to listen to and what to
read rather than testing them on points
of grammar that have been taught
if all of these things have happened the
student is satisfied with their own
level you have uh a record of their
level of activity
and you are in fact teaching in a way
that
enables them to be success happy with
their performance and that they are
active if you're doing all these things
you've done it and then we don't need to
measure you because we know that the
system works if that makes sense anyway
thank you for listening bye for now